Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui un petit numéro hors-série,
principalement pour vous parler du fait
que j'ai écrit un livre
qui sort aujourd'hui 17 février
et qui s'appelle :
" Mais qui a attrapé le bison de Higgs ? "
Alors je sais que il y en a qui vont dire :
" Oui, encore un Youtubeur qui fait un livre !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? "
" Est-ce que ça va être juste du copier-coller
des scripts des vidéos ? "
En fait, pas du tout.
Il y a une bonne raison pour ça,
c'est que je ne suis pas un vidéaste qui écrit un livre.
C'est plutôt l'inverse.
Il faut savoir qu'à la base,
je viens plutôt de l'écrit.
Ça fait maintenant plus de cinq ans
que je tiens un blog de vulgarisation scientifique
et ce livre a été écrit, quasiment dans son intégralité,
il y a, à peu près, un an et demi.
C'est-à-dire avant que je commence
à créer des vidéos.
Il est complètement indépendant
de ce que j'ai fait sur la chaîne
et j'ai même fait gaffe,
comme il était déjà écrit,
à ne pas traiter en vidéo trop de choses
que j'avais déjà traitées dans le livre.
Donc si vous regardez, en fait, il y a 2 3 redites,
mais à 90%, c'est des choses
que vous n'avez jamais vues sur la chaîne.
Qu'y a-t-il dans ce livre ?
Et bien, il y a 20 chapitres
et chacun répond
à une question scientifique
qui peut être de la physique,
de la chimie, de la bio, des maths
il y a même un peu de sciences sociales.
Et donc, à chaque fois,
je réponds de manière relativement complète.
Chaque chapitre fait 8-10 pages.
Avec pas mal de schémas,
comme vous avez par exemple l'habitude dans mes vidéos.
Et pour que chaque sujet soit introduit  un peu en douceur,
chaque chapitre commence par un dialogue
entre moi et l'une de mes filles
- déjà, c'est un prétexte pour raconter
un petit peu ma vie -
Puis, à la fin, ma fille est amenée
à me poser une question scientifique
toujours sous une forme
un petit peu naïve,
du genre :
" Mais qui a attrapé le bison de Higgs ? "
Enfin, dans le texte,
je réponds à cette question
d'une manière plus sérieuse
et plus classique.
Voilà des exemples de questions :
Comment sont apparues
les premières petites bêtes ?
Ou bien, est-ce que l'intérieur
de la terre est liquide ?
Est-ce que l'univers
a commencé un jour ?
Où se fabriquent les atomes ?
De plus, chaque chapitre
a été illustré par Lison Bernet,
que vous connaissez peut-être.
C'est une illustratrice
qui fait notamment "la BD du LHC".
C'est, en fait, un peu la maman
du Bison de Higgs.
Elle a donc illustré chaque chapitre
par un petit dessin assez onirique
que j'aime vraiment beaucoup
et qui apporte énormément
à la présentation du bouquin.
Le livre est disponible dans tous les bons endroits
où on vend des livres.
Donc dans votre librairie de quartier,
si elle l'a.
les grandes enseignes, certainement,
et, bien sûr, les habituels sites
de vente en ligne.
Je vous mettrai un lien, ici,
pour vous renvoyer vers tout ça.
Voilà, je suis très curieux
de savoir ce que vous en pensez
donc n'hésitez pas à me laisser des commentaires,
ici ou ailleurs
ainsi qu'à faire tourner l'information,
si le coeur vous en dit.
Alors, comme c'est un numéro
un peu hors-série
j'en profite pour vous parler
de deux chaînes que j'aime bien,
dont je pense
qu'elles mériteraient plus d'abonnés.
La première s'appelle "Passe-science".
C'est une chaîne qui traite de science,
en général
mais quand même
avec pas mal de physique fondamentale.
J'aime bien et pour commencer,
je vous recommande sa vidéo
sur le principe de relativité
qui est vraiment très bien.
C'est un principe qui est généralement
assez mal compris
et, là, je trouve qu'il l'explique
remarquablement bien.
Autre chaîne
que je vous recommande beaucoup :
elle s'appelle "Primum non nocere".
C'est du latin - excusez la prononciation -
Ça veut dire : "premièrement, ne pas nuire".
C'est une chaîne qui parle
essentiellement de biologie
et surtout de médecine.
C'est aussi une chaîne que j'aime bien
et vous pouvez commencer
par la vidéo sur le dopage, qui est très bien.
Voilà, merci d'être toujours
de plus en plus nombreux à suivre la chaîne.
Ça me fait vraiment très plaisir.
Comme d'habitude, n'hésitez pas
à la partager
avec votre famille, vos collègues,
vos amis,
vos ennemis aussi,
si ça vous amuse.
Et puis je vous dis :
" À bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos ! "